you are worth not living a numbed out
life
you are you are created for more than
that you're put here on Earth for more
than just to band it over how you feel
what you wanted what you think what you
need
and just go
you're worth more than that your life is
worth more than that your marriage is
worth more than that your time with your
kids and your friends are worth more
than that your time spent at work is
worth more than that don't settle for a
numbed out life
it's worth the work to head into the
storm and ask your body what are you
trying to protect me from what are you
trying to numb me out from what are you
trying to distract me from
and I gotta head right into the middle
of those storms
because that's where the light is that's
where the healing is